Rudy Giuliani Trump's so-called lawyer
but really as I mentioned a television
PR lawyer not a lawyer who's gonna do
stuff in court for Trump makes one
statement then he walks it back he calls
it a hypothetical quote of the president
he says he really doesn't know he's just
getting up to speed on the facts we've
heard that from Rudy before the latest
example of this is as I already told you
in the first story today he said in a
January 20th New York Times interview
that Donald Trump told him there were
Trump Tower Moscow discussions going on
quote from the day I announced till the
day I won the next day yesterday January
21st as I already told you Rudy Giuliani
walks it back and he says no no no that
was a hypothetical quote it's it wasn't
an actual quote of what Donald Trump
told me it was a hypothetical quote
which of course makes no grammatical
sense and it makes no material sense it
makes no sense of any kind
okay very strange walk back so then the
New Yorker gets a hold of Rudy Giuliani
and asks him about the walk back because
it's so strange and Rudy Giuliani
unprovoked starts talking about tapes
which as far as we knew didn't even
exist
check out the transcript of this
interview with The New Yorker and Rudy
Giuliani Giuliani says I guess the but
BuzzFeed story I don't remember what it
said about Cohen but it said there was
corroboration that the president talked
to Cohen and told him to lie about I
guess it was the Moscow proposal there
are no tapes there are no texts there is
no corroboration that the president told
him to lie I can tell you from the
moment I read the story I knew the story
was false because I have been through
all the tapes I have been through all
the texts I have been through all the
emails and I knew none existed to which
The New Yorker obviously says wait what
tapes have you gone through because
we're not aware of any such tapes and
Rudy Giuliani says I shouldn't have said
tapes they alleged there were texts and
emails that corroborated what Cohen was
saying the president told him to lie
there were no texts there were no emails
and the president never told him to lie
well I have listened to tapes but none
of them
concern this can anyone really be this
dumb or is it possible that Pat's right
which is that this is just idiots II as
a strategy the idea being that Giuliani
is a lawyer only in that he has a law
degree but for Trump
he's a PR guy on TV and as a PR guy on
TV he's not actually trying to make a
legal argument he's not stating what the
president's legal position is on any of
this stuff he is not even really trying
to appeal to the rational audience he's
trying to keep Trump's base engaged and
reasonably giving some plausible
deniability that they can say we don't
think Trump actually did anything wrong
so he's going out there and deliberately
sowing confusion he says a and then he
says the opposite of a and it's all to
muddy the waters it's all to make it
impossible to actually know what's going
on and to keep the Trump is relatively
happy that everything's fine and Trump
is just a great guy the part that's
difficult for me to believe about that
Pat is that I just don't think
Giuliani's a good enough actor to this
fluidly or this genuinely seemed as
though he actually spoke mistakenly like
if this was planned to now float the
idea of tapes and then immediately say I
didn't mean that there actually aren't
any tapes I just don't think the guys
are good enough actor to pull it off
isn't that where the term useful idiot
comes from like maybe he doesn't realize
that he's playing that role he's
genuinely trying to do a good job but he
keeps falling flat on his face and they
realized the administration does that
this is good for them and that's why
they keep him going
and that well the important thing with
that idea again is none of Rudy
Giuliani's media interviews are
assertions about Trump's legal position
at a matter is in terms of what he's
telling Robert Moeller for example this
is just Rudy running his mouth on TV
it's not legally binding in that sense
but if tapes genuinely exist we've
suspected that for some time now the
question becomes will we ever actually
get access to them so this could be a DC
it could be deliberately planting
conflicting stories but importantly it's
incidentally relevant what rudy guiliani
says from a legal standpoint the
question were left with is do the tapes
exist what do you think I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the shows on Twitter at D
Pakman we'll take a David Pakman show
rather we'll take a quick break and be
back after this one of the day's
sponsors is privacy dot-com / Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy com
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy com icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link